What's up with the color color colors of Chameeeleons,
they come and go.
They come and go!
Changing color is a rarity in the animal world,
and also a mystery, until now!
Hey everybody thank you for watching DNews
today.
I'm Trace and I am right here on our brand
new set!
Chameleons change color so well, and are so
well known across the planet for doing so,
that their name is synonymous with someone
who is good at changing their look, behavior
or opinions as their situation changes.
Most people think chameleons change color
for camouflage, but that's not it at all!
Only the males can change color, and they
do so to communicate danger to other nearby
chameleons, or for a mating display.
Ladies.
*wink*
It's a pretty dramatic show when a chameleon
swaps its green for bright red, and thanks
to new research, we now know HOW they do it.
Researchers from the University of Geneva
looked at the skin cells of chameleons to
observe how they change color.
Within their skin, it turns out, chameleons
have cells called iridophores.
Suspended within those cells are tiny guanine
nanocrystals which are formed into a lattice.
When relaxed, the chameleons’ iridophore
lattices are contracted, and mainly reflect
blue light, but when excited the chameleon
expands and three dimensional lattices expand
along with them, reflecting different wavelengths
of light!
Below that layer, there's a layer of skin
with even larger nanocrystals which reflect
near-infrared light; providing "passive thermal
protection."
Which is great, because these cold-blooded
animals can't change their body temperature;
changing that base layer may be one way they
can affect how much near-infrared light, and
therefore heat, is absorbed into their body,.
Camouflage is also called cryptic coloration;
or a color and pattern that makes an animal
difficult to discern from its surroundings;
concealing it.
The ability to CHANGE colors isn't unique
to chameleons -- some fish, frogs, insects,
crustaceans, cephalopods, and other lizards
can do it too, but they don't have nanocrystals…
this research is the first time that's been
seen in reptiles.
And other animals use different methods of
color shifting.
Cuttlefish, for example, can also change their
colors at will; but rather than crystal-filled
iridophores, they use chromatophores.
Chromatophores are sacs of a single pigment
of color surrounded by muscle.
The cuttlefish has learned to widen or constrict
that sac to show more or less of that color.
Invertebrates like cephalopods use these chromatophores
too, and for more on that you can check out
our video exploring how the disco clam can
reflect light like a disco ball!
Over time, evolution, mutation and simply
breeding with others can cause changes in
the colors of species, humans included -- all
blue-eyed humans descend from a single mutated
ancestor.
Usually because those animals which have these
colorful adaptations tend to survive better.
Zebra stripes confuse predatory eyes, helping
to disguise individuals and making the herd
look more massive; background matching camouflage
helps both predators like tigers blend with
their environment; as well as helping their
prey hide by resembling it's surroundings…
but these adaptations take many generations
to develop!
Active color change is pretty rare in the
Animal Kingdom.
Before this research, scientists believed
chameleons changed color the same as cuttlefish
or octopuses, but once they put the skin cells
into a super-magnifying electron microscope,
they were able to see this unique and super
cool system for reflecting light!
How do you think humans camouflage into our
surroundings?
Do we?
Why or why not...